[Music]
so something's going on with joe biden
his poll numbers are absolutely tanking
but it seems like elements within the
democratic party are turning on him
we're not going to pretend we understand
exactly what's going on here but
something definitely is
here's this example you remember this
very well just before the last election
the new york post ran a story about the
contents of hunter biden's laptop it was
a huge story with big tech censored it
immediately cnn and dozens of other
former intel officials told us that
laptop was russian disinformation
there are fears that what giuliani is
now pushing here in the united states
could actually be part of russia's
latest and very massive disinformation
campaign in the u.s presidential
election so you have a president who is
asking to obtain russian disinformation
knowing that that is what it is he is
accepting that same information and he
is then turning it and using it on the
campaign trail against his his opponent
and that's mind-blowing it's sort of
a crazy quilt at this point
which has all the hallmarks of russian
disinformation that said it wasn't for
lack of trying cnn reported on friday
that u.s authorities are seeing if those
emails we just talked about are
connected to an ongoing russian
disinformation effort
so it turns out when they accuse people
of russian disinformation they're not
always sincere of course they're liars
they'll say whatever they need to say
that was before the election they needed
to get biden elected they did it
but now they're telling you something
very different now they're telling you
in fact the laptop is real here's cnn
yesterday
this is very very bad for the
president's son
it is and it's an investigation as you
pointed out going back to 2018 and right
now prosecutors in delaware
are focusing on a number of things
including whether hunter biden and some
of his business associates
violated laws including attacks and
money laundering laws and foreign
lobbying laws they're now gaining steam
and they need to make a decision i think
in the at least intermediate future this
case has been going on for four years
and there is a realistic chance this
could result in federal charges of
course then we'd be in unprecedented
political territory not legal territory
but a situation of having potentially
the justice department prosecuting and
trying to imprison the son of the
president
what a freak show that channel is good
luck to their new subscription service
but now they're telling you yeah it's
all true actually and that's not the
only story about russian disinformation
that has fallen apart this week the
federal election commission just fined
the dnc and hillary clinton her campaign
more than a hundred thousand dollars the
fec determined that the clinton campaign
tried to hide its role in funding the
steele dossier steele dossier is the
false document that claimed among many
other things
that putin got trump elected turns out
the disinformation
was in fact
paid for
by the campaign
it was coming from the dnc
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight